McDonald's found liable for Hot Chicken
McNugget that fell from Happy Meal and
burned girl how hot was this nugget it
just was a fiery Little Nugget that fell
on this girl or did the mother did A
desperate mother
take a nugget in a car I want you to
Picture This a mother who's had enough a
mother who can't get ahead
a mother who knows
that things don't get better now listen
baby mommy has to hurt you right now
mommy has to hurt you but you know that
Mommy loves you mommy would only ever
hurt you if she had to right
now it's gonna hurt a little bit when I
put this McNugget I lit up on your leg
you understand that and you go scream
and that's okay you can scream loud
before she has the chance like second
guess it she goes
and the girl goes and the girl just
because it's so she's branding her
daughter with a nugget